hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
on this channel we've seen plenty of
cases of scams and frauds
but what if the very same financial
institutions who we trust with our money
end up committing some of the biggest
frauds of all time
it's not fun to think about but it's
almost a fact of life now now don't get
me wrong not all banks are bad but some
of the largest financial institutions
are no stranger to deceit
in this episode we'll take a look at
some of the biggest frauds ever
committed by banks and then will end on
an exclusive story for rob bestian a
licensed stockbroker of over 8 years who
has agreed to publicly blow the whistle
here on cold fusion
rob used to work at one of the biggest
banks in the united states but has since
left
let's begin
you are watching pearl fusion tv
[Music]
up first we have the wells fargo fake
account scandal
wells fargo the third largest bank in
the united states ruined their
reputation in one big catastrophe
it all started when wells fargo
executives wanted their staff to meet
aggressive sales targets in their
financial products business
these products were things like
mortgages or credit cards
employees who met these targets were
eligible for promotions and bonuses
while employees who did not meet these
sales targets faced relentless pressure
and even termination
success by retail banks was measured in
part by the average number of products
held by a customer
so to appear more successful wells fargo
employees then created millions of
savings and checkings accounts for
customers without their knowledge or
approval
why because they wanted to sell multiple
products to the same customers
for example a customer with a checking
account might also be given a credit
card that they didn't ask for
to achieve the sales goals set forth by
the company bank branch staff resorted
to inappropriate activities they started
using their own contact information on
forms to prevent customers from
discovering the scam
employees were accused of creating
fraudulent checkings and savings
accounts by moving money out of existing
accounts into the new ones
this was made possible by setting the
customer's pin numbers to zero zero zero
zero
now the bankers had full control of the
client's accounts without them knowing
as early as 2011 the wall street journal
smelt a rat and ran a story of the
illegal practices but nobody really
cared
another article in 2013 was published by
the los angeles times this time it
focused on the intense pressure on bank
managers and individual bankers to
produce ever increasing sales and even
mathematically impossible quotas but
still
nobody cared
eventually many of the bank's customers
noticed something strange they
questioned fees on accounts that they
didn't ask for or didn't even realize
they owned
the influx of complaints finally drew
the attention of regulatory agencies
the fraud started to gain wider
attention in 2016 when a group of
government regulatory agencies fined the
bank a combined 185 million so that's my
question about wells fargo how far up
the line did this go this generation of
executives that either could have known
or should have known and in some cases
we talked to people and they said look
they were told they were told that there
were suspicious numbers on the platform
here and they decided not to do anything
about it i mean someone told us 42 debit
accounts by a single banker in southern
california nobody said as a manager hey
that looks a little bit fishy maybe i
should look into that perhaps this is
made up wells fargo subsequently dealt
with civil and criminal lawsuits and
paid out over 2.7 billion dollars
john stumpf wells fargo chief executive
at the height of the scandal was forced
to resign
when all was said and done the bank had
created over 3.5 million fraudulent
accounts
but wells fargo traded its hard-earned
reputation for short-term profits
and harmed untold numbers of customers
along the way i had 15 accounts at once
it was just very frustrating and these
are accounts i never opened
interest rates are an important part of
any economy
but what if the interest rate of
corporate loans student loans mortgages
and more were all controlled by a single
mechanism a mechanism that was
fraudulently being altered
the london interbank offered rate
otherwise known as libor rate is exactly
that
the libor scandal was probably the
biggest financial crime that you've
never heard of one way of judging how
healthy they were was by how much
interest they were paying to borrow cash
which would also affect the cost of
mortgages and loans the way libor worked
was that each bank had to estimate how
much interest they'd have to pay to
borrow cash then the rates from all the
banks were averaged that's the libor
rate in total libor itself underpins 350
trillion dollars of value based in
derivatives
by manipulating the libor the traders in
question were inherently causing a
cascade of mispriced financial assets
throughout the entire global financial
system
the libor is supposed to be the total
assessment of health of the financial
system because if the banks feel
confident about the state of things they
report a low interest number and if the
member banks feel a low degree of
confidence and see risk in the financial
system they report a higher interest
rate number the huge flaw in this
approach was that the estimates that the
bank gave on interest rates was being
used to determine the actual libor
interest rate
none of the banks actually had to borrow
and lend at the same rate mentioned in
libel the banks merely had to tell the
regulators that they would do so
in practice they would be borrowing and
lending at completely different rates
they could then profit on the difference
between what they reported and what they
actually traded with
banks realized that they could form a
cartel and rig the libor rate in their
favor
they got together and consistently
fudged their numbers they were providing
inflated or deflated interest rates to
regulators for years
unfortunately the fraud also impacted
corporations and individuals who had
loans based on the libor
for the banks there was a lot of money
to be made in the first quarter of 2009
citigroup had interest rate swaps of a
notional value of 14.2 trillion and bank
of america 49.7 trillion
these are huge numbers and just a small
change in the libor rate can make them
piles of cash
for example a one percent interest rate
change that happens instantaneously
could see billions in profit
and there was much affected in the real
world
one example is home mortgages homeowners
in the united states filed a class
action lawsuit in october 2012. the
lawsuit was against 12 of the largest
banks that were fudging the numbers in
the libor rate and this made mortgage
repayments more expensive than they
should have been deutsche bank was one
of the biggest participants in the fraud
they were fined 1.74 billion dollars
anz bank in australia barclays bank in
the uk and the royal bank of scotland
were some of the other banks involved
the fines offered were nothing compared
to the money that they made
[Music]
gold and silver market rigging by jp
morgan
in 1974 the futures market began trading
in the gold and silver markets
futures contracts are basically an
agreement for two parties to trade an
asset at an agreed date and price
in this case both parties are trading
gold and silver
as time went on more and more futures
contracts were created at will
essentially increasing the virtual
supply of gold and silver when in
reality no new metal was ever mined
in fact the prices and the amount of
gold and silver traded have very little
to do with the underlying supply of
metals
as you could imagine this system was
ripe for abuse
by 2018 more imaginary gold and silver
was traded in a few days than was
actually mined in an entire year in 2018
only 34 tons of registered gold stocks
were delivered through futures contracts
and yet 260 000 tons of gold was traded
on the comex which is more gold than has
ever been mined in history and 86 times
the annual gold mining supply
[Music]
between 2008 and 2016 jp morgan engaged
in a practice that manipulated the price
of gold and silver what they were doing
was something called spoofing
this manipulative practice is designed
to create the illusion of demand or a
lack thereof
the goal of spoofing is to move market
prices in a way that financially
benefits the banks
for a very long time this idea was
labeled as a conspiracy theory to summon
the financial industry
in an interview with cnbc aired in april
2013 financial whistleblower andrew
mcguire described how mysterious traders
allegedly working for jp morgan waited
till most of the major markets closed
and then used a separate market known as
the comex to trade virtual silver
anonymously they used algorithms to
bounce in and out of the futures market
in the blink of an eye 400 contracts a
second
the thing is each contract represents 5
000 troy ounces of silver
in one instance maguire described
unusual market movements that saw the
sale of 45 000 contracts with a profit
of eighty thousand dollars per contract
totaling a profit of 3.6 billion dollars
for the mystery seller
these kind of strange market movements
weren't that unusual
the difference between the digital gold
traded on the futures market versus the
actual amount of physical gold that
actually exists has now become so vast
that now there are hundreds of claims of
ownership on every single ounce of gold
in other words for every ounce of gold
exchanged in the futures market each
trader thinks that they have a claim to
that gold and could take physical
delivery of the metal if needed but the
thing is hundreds more traders also
think the same thing
let's just hope everyone doesn't want
their physical gold at once
in 2019 jp morgan was accused of being
quote a criminal enterprise by a federal
prosecutor for the rigging of the gold
and silver market
in september of 2020 the department of
justice issued a 920 million dollar fine
for the rigging in reality they could be
potentially earning trillions so
ultimately these fines are just the cost
of doing business and the practice still
continues to this day um you know
they've been spoofing the market for the
better part of eight years and
silver uh gold platinum palladium i mean
all of the precious metals uh this is a
pretty big deal i mean there's always
talk and listen i've been covering gold
for almost eight years now and there's
always talk of people saying oh there's
some sort of manipulation going in the
market you probably hear that in every
market um but now that this actually
comes up it really kind of makes you
think twice like wow i mean this is this
is interesting i mean this is they're
claiming racketeering charges these are
high claims
for the second half of this video we're
going to take a deep dive into the next
scandal which is still ongoing today
one of the biggest frauds of all
possibly in the hundreds of billions of
dollars is the etn scandal
this one is notable because it's still
ongoing this has flown under the radar
of the general public and was brought to
my attention by rob bestian a broker of
eight years he's looked pretty deeply
into the situation with these products
and believes that this is one of the
largest financial frauds of all time
after launching a complaint to the sec
he's agreed to talk to me about what's
happening but before we look into it we
need to set the groundwork
it all begins with a class of products
called an exchange traded note or etn
etns have proven extremely risky
transferring all the risk and losses to
buyers while the banks make a profit
as you'll see some analysts have claimed
that they literally serve no economic
purpose
banks such as ubs group and citigroup
and notoriously credit suites have all
taken part
so what are atns
[Music]
according to the sec etns are unsecured
debt obligations
this means that they aren't backed by
any underlying asset and etn is
basically a figment of imagination by
wall street financial engineers
the point of them is to mimic the
performance of an underlying index such
as oil or foreign currencies but it's
not backed by them
they are in practice iou's from a bank
which promises to deliver the returns of
an index in return for a fee
leveraged etns can offer multiples of
the performance of an index
inverse etns are based on the opposite
performance
[Music]
when the price of an etn goes down banks
make money so naturally what does the
price do over an extended period of time
it goes down the long term value of an
etn is engineered to go to zero
credit suisse even said so for example
the reverse vix etn which mirrors the
reverse price action of an index that
measures the volatility in the stock
market states that quote the long-term
expected value of your etn is zero if
you hold on to your etn as a long-term
investment it is likely that you will
lose all or a substantial portion of
your investment end quote
the only issue is that this was buried
in page 197 of their prospectus far from
a place where the casual buyer would be
aware
in short the issuers which are the big
banks want the price of these etns to
drop as quickly as possible then they
mark to mark up the gains on their
balance sheet
we'll have rob who'll give us his
rundown on the fraud that he's uncovered
a link to his full video will be in the
description below
hi my name is rob bashian over the next
few minutes i would like to go over two
major parts of my whisper complaints
first i will explain the mechanics and
mathematics of how leveraged and inverse
exchange strategy products operate
second i will discuss the extreme use of
reverse splits
i've constructed a narrative or game to
demonstrate the basic yet
counterintuitive mathematics of the
fraud in this narrative there are three
participants two players and the house
the players win based on opposite
outcomes of the flip of a coin both
players will start with a thousand
dollars and the house will collect the
losses and pay out the winnings the
house's balance will only increase if
there is a net loss by both players upon
first observation one might think this
is a binary outcome with an equal
probability of profit and loss just as a
coin flip is binary one winner and one
loser
let's play 10 rounds and see just how
wrong that assumption is
as you can see from this table the house
took 60 percent of the pot without ever
taking financial risk investing any of
their own funds or adding economic value
player 1 won 60 percent of the time and
still lost 29
and player 2 suffered a devastating loss
this is exactly the way leverage and
inverse etns and their pairs work they
are mathematically and i repeat
mathematically guaranteed to go down 100
of the time and the more time that goes
by the more dramatic the decline these
products were designed and constructed
this way on purpose to enrich the
issuers the distributors the brokers and
advisors that peddled this
so why would people in their right mind
buy something that the price is
guaranteed to go to zero
well as it turns out it's possible that
they don't know that the value is going
down at all through some financial
trickery banks can avoid suspicion by
manipulating the price of these products
so how does this work
well through a neat trick called a
reverse split an issuer of an etn can
reduce the number of shares to increase
the price for example in a ten to one
reverse split there are one tenth the
number of shares but the price of each
share has increased ten times
in the end the net asset value stays the
same but the price looks 10 times higher
to an uneducated outsider
reverse splits falsely caused the etn
price to be higher than it otherwise
would have been and this allows issuers
to create additional notes at a higher
price
the higher the starting price the more
money the banks make remember the
issuing financial institutions are
constantly creating more notes and
selling them to market
reverse splits allow them to issue notes
at a higher price certainly few
investors would purchase a security
which was priced at twenty dollars
eighteen months ago and now trades it
under one an etn called the tvx started
at a price of two billion in december of
2010 but by december of 2019 its price
was 51.29
so
it's actually down 99.99992
in the example of tvx over the course of
seven years 2012-2019 25 million notes
were converted to one
let me repeat 25 million to one making
the etm price 25 million times larger
than it should have been
so where did that 2 billion go
out of the hands of investors and into
the pockets of the banks
ugas another etn which mimics the
performance of the natural gas sector
does the same as the product continued
to decay the banks would continue to
carry out reverse splits at the expense
of unsuspecting investors these were all
part of my original complaint and sense
had been delisted but no fines to the
issuers coincidence probably
under this logic
if enron had just done large enough
reverse splits and issued more stock at
a higher manipulated price it would
still be a 60 security and in great
financial health the other thing you
have to keep in mind too is that unlike
an etf these exchange-traded notes don't
have a board um so there really isn't
this oversight um you know uh you know
committee to sort of uh look over those
things so uh these exchange traded notes
they're like hey look why don't we just
do the same kind of thing and put it out
there and see what happens but then they
get they get left um without anyone
really
you know to to account for it and it's
uh it's a problem these are not exchange
traded funds these are notes and and
it's you know everyone's
in 2018 a credit suisse reverse vix etn
exploded hurting investors but leaving
the bank unscathed
paul gambles co-founder of financial
advisory firm mbmg group called it quote
an accident waiting to happen and he
stated that the products served no
economic purpose
the product was blamed for causing a
negative feedback loop of market selling
the banks lost no money but the holders
of the etn did the bank actually booked
profits for the loss of value of the
fund
to make things worse these financial
products are passed through distributors
and sellers to unknowing unsophisticated
investors a move which most would call
predatory behaviour
in his professional career rob has seen
similar things go on
after much controversy credit suisse
de-listed their u-gas etn in july of
2020
on looking at this to test out his
theory rob decided to mirror what the
banks were doing
he consistently made significant profits
in the markets and this is one of the
number one red flags in trading the same
flag that alerted investigators to jump
onto bernie madoff
let's pull up some etn pair charts and
see if my game analysis plays out in
real life
by mimicking what the issuers do
legally it's possible to generate
returns well in excess of 40 a year
every year
this in my opinion is the nail in the
coffin of any defense of these products
by regulators or by the issuers when the
world learns of the fraud and can follow
along in real time the opportunity to
exploit the public
which is fraud does goes away
i can guarantee i'm not the only one
that knows how these products operate
they were designed this way on purpose
and i'm willing to bet there are
powerful hedge funds
shorting the
out of these products and making
billions it's important to remember etns
are considered debt on the issuer's
balance sheet
as the price of the etns decrease
their profit from issuing the security
increases with further investigation it
was found that these products weren't
tracking their underlying indexes
properly in march 2020 many of these
products were collapsing in dramatic
fashion both leveraged etn anti-etfs
which i had predicted months before in
my sec filings
remember these should have inverse
performance intraday meaning if one was
down 10 its inverse pair should be up
ten percent this did not happen
another failure
at the expense of purchasers and with
measurable direct benefit to the issuers
as they marked to market these products
with huge multi-billion dollar daily
gains is this fair or is this fraud
most of the etns i listed in my initial
whistleblower complaints and all etns
from credit suisse have now been
delisted
but not before many of the issuers made
many tens of billions are they going to
quietly escape into the night without
criticism
keeping tens of billions of investors
money
that's up to you and me the sec recently
fined some of these parties for these
products which was part of my initial
complaint as well as a large point of my
discussion with the sec on the phone in
march of 2020. to rob the whole scheme
of leveraged and inverse etns appears to
be a giant fraud
rob has submitted two whistleblower
complaints to the sec the last of which
was in the 2nd of january 2020. these
complaints usually progress slowly and
take years to play out harry markopoulos
who uncovered the bernie madoff ponzi
scheme was ignored and not believed for
years but once bernie's fraud fell apart
everyone was willing to listen but not
before
so in summary knowing that the banks are
cheating and rigging their way at the
expense of others isn't anything new but
seeing the extent that some institutions
go to is staggering
from creating fake accounts to rigging
the gold and silver markets to the
rigging of interest rates and creating
fake financial instruments it really
makes you wonder
and we didn't even touch on the
derivative bets that went wrong that
made the housing crisis in america turn
into a global financial issue
or the 2019 rigging of the currency
exchange market that involved 11 banks
and so much more it's clear that there's
plenty of corruption out there but
hopefully justice can be served over
time
the hope of this episode is that at a
minimum it raises questions to those
that have a responsibility to keep our
financial system running with honesty
keep investors protected and at a
minimum dive deeper
is it likely that any regulators are
going to admit dropping the ball and not
adequately protecting investors it's
important we ask these and more tough
questions and bring this to broader
attention so if anyone out there is
watching that is a regulator or at least
has some sway take a look into the etn
issue
regarding the etn fraud and related
products rob is in the process of
submitting a third whistleblower
complaint to the sec he's going to
provide a mathematical proof or white
paper describing the mathematics behind
the fraud and how he's able to generate
such large profits essentially only by
mimicking the issuers of the product
he'll be making this information public
shortly if you want to know more details
about the fraud i'll leave a link to
rob's video below
for me personally although i can't 100
be sure i do think it looks suspicious
if rob's claim of making returns in
excess of 40 per year is indeed true
there are some huge questions that
should be raised with regulators
okay so that's about it from me thanks
for watching the whole way through
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you